this actually might not be as hard as I
thought but then again with the last
cheesecake I got cocky
and then I made seven
[Music]
hi I'm Ken I'm a tasty producer and
today I'm gonna be testing a four
flavored cheesecake it's all gonna be
made in one pan and I want to find out
if it's possible and if it works I'll
make a video out of it how do I keep the
flavors from not mixing together so my
first thought is these graham crackers
which these are all broken step 1 make
sure your graham crackers aren't broken
because nothing will work I think if I
wrap these in foil I can get it to be a
bit sturdier look at this I can do a
wedge so this is my pan so the goal is
to make sure that chocolate and lemon
don't touch caramel and raspberry can go
either way because it doesn't really
matter they're okay this is where it
gets stressful you'd add gelatin to my
cream and whisk it in there slowly pour
hot gelatin cream into of the cream
cheese that is a lot of very liquidy
batter the batter needs to be like to
hold it and right now it's like really
thin you know what it'll be fine I'm
just gonna divide into four equal parts
so two and a quarter into each Bowl oh
they do my math wrong why does it feel
like there's nothing left this is
correct math I'm so sure of it I mean
there's not have to be perfect today I
just want to find out if it work
we put all these in the fridge and
they'll become cold and then if a whip
it it should be thick and then it won't
be ruined
always working it is sturdy look at that
chocolate is nice and melty it'll is a
good amount of chocolate it's like a
it's brown let's go with the tablespoon
of lemon curd
yes should be alright for now I'm just
gonna dollop this I don't want it to be
perfect
I just or like pink probably already too
much if you think I'm at that point
where oh holy bejesus I need to make a
crust touch the sugar
press it down really tight screen I see
I think I need a new course of action
this actually might work they're kind of
standing up let's see if they're sturdy
enough to put batter into so far so good
okay so they usually promise with this
one oh god this is not gonna be a pretty
one but lessons learned think a lot of
progress has been made today from the
first batch they realized they made too
much batter so I'm gonna try another
batter reduced by a third this is
already so much about it in the first
batter I'm just gonna divide it using my
eyes is that smart smooth sailing this
is so much easier last time I have a
like measure and deed math it's gonna
pour in the butter zip and she before it
was just like all loose and now it's
like able to crunch together and compact
this which is what you want for all
those little bits to become one the
double crust is also another reason why
I reduce the batter I mean normally like
crust is like a great way to have like a
foundation for your cheesecake this is
working this is properly working this
isn't thinner than my last batter so
like I don't think it's as firm as the
other ones
there's definitely not enough of his
batter because all the other cakes took
it all
I mean it's working it's not pretty I
really want to practice making it look
good because they have chocolate he's in
like candy and at the exact number so
next layer is the lemon curd and I'm
just gonna spread she's gonna go for the
whole chocolate turtle vibe caramels
hurtle turtle okay looks like there's
cockroaches on the cheesecake
raspberries time swirl around Suzy's
right now it was almost perfect that
looks weird but you know it's fine it's
not gonna be using them I think it's
very safe to say that this cheesecake
it's come a long way from the first one
to the second one I think day three will
be the one I forget about day three
day three is like not as scary because
they know what I'm doing finally so to
do that I'm doing two cups instead of
three cups of heavy whipping cream and I
hope that there'll be no waste hopefully
not too little is it too little
no this one's too low too of course
that's one that has plenty this battery
messed up because there's too little so
they need to all be level and I'm kind
of over in it for today I thought today
be done and nothing would go wrong so
I'm just gonna get ready for day four
today I can finally cut the cake right
now I need to figure out how to get it
out of the pan it's on the interweb that
you could use a blowtorch to help soften
up the edges
[Music]
it definitely feels less cold around the
edge so I think I'm gonna try using the
knife now oh I'm edible torch too much
they can feel my edges being a little
melty oh I feel like I might have melted
it too much
oh wait oh my god it's just like the
crust down there and I'm gonna put it on
a cake plate it's gonna put the whole
thing in the freezer for a couple of
minutes all right it's time for the
moment of truth it's coming off
[Music]
ha looks nice from the top there's
something up with this caramel of one
because everything else seems so much
more firm gravity does not agree with
that one
maybe because a caramel sauce brand is
like really thin compared to everything
else I don't want to make another
cheesecake but something needs to be
changed
I know I'm gonna have to making you
better hopefully only one more today is
not the day I think it's C 5
maybe they 12 but I finally solved the
caramel problem so caramel itself has so
much water in it and that's why the
cheesecake wouldn't set so I'm gonna use
dulce de leche which is a lot thicker
than caramel and hopefully will hold
together it's like a lot thicker and a
little more golden what have I learned
oh boy I have learned that you should
not give up on anything because every
little curve was the easy fix
you just took a little bit of like
grieving time to sort out it's ready go
and pop in the fridge and four hours
later we'll have like a beautiful
perfect four flavors cheesecake so I
don't have words to describe how excited
I am right now
[Music]
who
oh yeah
that is what I'm talking about look at
that that is one solid yet creamy
cheesecake the past month I have been
developing it's very crazy but very
delicious recipe for for flavor
cheesecake in one pan and finally it is
done and I am happy it is beautiful
people like it and hopefully our
audience likes it you can I go home
[Music]